diana buenos días para usted y cuéntenos
cómo será el proceso para designar el
reemplazo de arbey y los republicanos ya
dijeron que planean un voto
así es el líder de el senado el
republicano mcconnell dijo que planeaba
un voto y que lo planean este año aunque
el presidente de un halcón básicamente
él dio su pesar sus condolencias a la
familia y no dio ningún anuncio más allá
se abría una fecha o no y básicamente es
el presidente quién tendría que decidir
entre una serie de candidatos a su
nominado este proceso para entrevistar a
los candidatos para hacer una
verificación de antecedentes tarde en
promedio cerca de tres meses una vez el
presidente escoge a su nominado y hace
el anuncio desde la casa blanca es el
senado el que tiene que pasar por esta
verificación de nuevo y hacer la
votación en este momento el senado tiene
la mayoría republicana y sólo se
necesita la mitad más un voto para que
pueda ser elegido quien sea el nuevo
miembro o la mujer que vaya a reemplazar
esta silla vacante para la corte y esto
va a dictar también durante las próximas
décadas si sería una corte más
conservadora o sería una corte
liberal el presidente de donald trump ha
nominado dos miembros de la corte y han
sido aprobados por el senado pero no se
sabe qué pasará en medio de las
elecciones presidenciales bueno de anna
precisamente donald trump anunció
recientemente que tiene una lista de
candidatos conservadores cuáles son los
más opcionados y qué implicaciones
tendría la llegada de uno de ellos al
máximo tribunal
así después básicamente el presidente
había dicho en varias oportunidades
anteriormente que tenía una lista de 20
candidatos algunos de estos candidatos
más conocidos por ejemplo son el senador
de cruz por el estado de florida el
senador cotton por arkansas también el
actual embajador de mexico y pues el
presidente dijo básicamente también que
estaba preparado para nominar a un
tercer candidato a suplir esta silla
pero esto fue meses atrás
ahora bien venden también dijo que si
llegara a ser elegido que nombraría a
una mujer afroamericana y que también
comenzaría a hacer su lista de
candidatos la corte suprema- toma
decisiones tan relevantes como por
ejemplo temas sobre aborto derechos
civiles y libertades laborales así que
quien llegue podría marcar
definitivamente la balanza hacia una
corte más conservadora o hacia un área
más liberal pero lo que puede pasar es
que el precio
y digamos si el presidente de donald
trump llega a perder antes de dejar la
casa blanca y un periodo en donde podría
iluminar en los próximos meses de
comienzos de 2021 a su favorito esto le
pasó al presidente barack obama en 2016
pero no fue confirmado en el senado